Ladies, the point of this exercise
is to see if I am fit for the
Israeli Army, is that correct?
Yes.
I have quick moves.
(laughter)
Wow, nice.
Will any of that be good in a fight?
A fight with clowns.
(laughter)
You're a mess.
What do you mean I'm a mess?
You're supposed to build up my confidence,
not say I'm a mess.
You know, if a battle started now,
I would be, all day,
putting on this kneepad.
I'll be right there, you got them!
Almost there, hold on!
Almost there and the battle's over.
The battle's over.
Oh my gosh.
Let's be honest, I look like a chef.
Alright, what do I do first?
Climbing over a wall.
I gotta get over this wall my first shot?
Yeah.
You know there is another
way, you mind moving aside?
Look at this.
(applause)
Yes, very good, use your legs.
Up, up.
Adin!
What?
Adin, get in here, hold my legs!
Adin, yes!
Adin!
Push!
On my ass!
Feel that.
I don't have?
Oh god.
Okay.
Feels good.
Wait, I can't walk!
Yes.
Yeah!
It's amazing.
Almost finished.
Look, I got a cut!
I got a cut!
Call the helicopter!
Look at that!
(somber music)